اعتقد في الوقت الحالي ان بامكان القول ان
التقدم الذي حققناه في الاسبوعين الماضيين
يجعلنا في موقع افضل مما كنا عليه قبل
اسابيع اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري يؤكد احراز تقدم في
المفاوضات للتوصل الى صفقه بين اسرائيل
وحماس ويشدد على انها الفرصه الوحيده
المتاحه لتهدئه الوضع بكن يقول ان قطر
تقوم بدور مهم في الوساطه واهنيه يؤكد
تسلم مقترح اجتماع باريس ويقول ان حماس
بصدد دراسته تجدون المزيد من اخبار الحرب
على غزه في رابط
بالتعليقات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول ان
اوكرانيا حاولت تنفيذ هجوم واسع النطاق
وصفته بالارهابي ضد اهداف على الاراضي
الروسيه وبيان باسم الوزاره يوضح ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي روسيه دمرت 21 مسيره
اوكرانيه توزعت في اجواء شبه جزيره القرم
ومنطقه بجرود ومقاطعات
اخرى محكمه باكستانيه خاصه تدين كلا من
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان ووزير
خارجيته شاه محمود قريشي وتحكم عليهما
بالسجن لعشر سنوات بتهمه تسريب فحوى رساله
بعث بها السفير الباكستاني السابق في
واشنطن تتحدث عن تفاصيل لقاء جمعه بمسؤول
في الخارجيه
الامريكيه شركه تويوتا موتور تقول انها
باعت 11 مليو و2 الف سياره في عام
2023 لتحافظ على مركزها الاول في بيع
السيارات للعام الرابع على التوالي وتسجل
اعلى رقم مبيعات في تاريخ الشركه
اليابانيه الى
اللقاء
ه